okay can you hear me
all right so welcome everyone I'm David
door the vice chair of the department
this is an informatics discovery lab
lecture which feels a lot like the
department of medical informatics and
clinical epidemiology lecture but it's a
little more special in some way and you
know our focus is really partnering with
industry to really figure out
next-generation solutions to real
problems getting understanding them
working on them developing them in
partnership with industry and I'm kind
of lucky today because I have my good
friend viet nguyen coming to talk from a
company systems made simple about being
a CMIO and viet is really somebody that
I I respect and we actually trained
together in Utah many years ago as
medical informations he coming enroute
from getting his MD at University of
Utah and then going and doing a medic
medicine and Pediatrics joint residency
at and Cincinnati and being a chief at
Cincinnati Children's and then coming
back to join me at the University of
Utah informatics and so it's really
useful I think for us to think about the
differences in our careers and where
we've ended up and how much good we can
sort of do in different aspects I in
academics II and industry of the
informatics world today it's really
something pretty impressive I think that
informatics has really gotten to the
point where industry really appreciates
and needs people like Viet who I admire
so much so I with that I will stop and
to him let him go ahead thank you thank
you very much dr. Hirsch is here but I
want to thank dr. Hurst and the
department for inviting us to to come
visit I'm here today with Rob Sachs he's
the chief technology officer for SMS and
here to to talk to the ideal group about
ways we can collaborate and work
together and bring that academic
commercial collaboration to fruition and
bring value into healthcare IT so
I'm not big on done giving like
presentations we're slide next slide
read the slide
I'd prefer this to be a discussion
because personally I actually do better
having conversation with folks than
talking to them so feel free to stop me
at any time and what I'm going to do is
is to use these slides to help kind of
guide our conversation to give you a
little bit more kind of perspective on
where I came from
after the informatics
fellowship in Utah I had to make kind of
career decisions as we all do and to
decide okay now I have this informatics
training and I really like it and it's
really interesting stuff but I was
trained as a doctor and I'm a
pediatrician I'm an internist and I
really should be using some of these
skills and so I started a practice which
I don't really recommend anymore to
people and I started internal medicine
to Pediatrics practice with a partner
and we opened it in Park City Utah which
is a fabulous place to work beautiful
scenery and so we provided inpatient and
outpatient care and a few years after we
started practice Intermountain
Healthcare which is a vertically
integrated delivery network in Utah
opened a community hospital there and so
we had this outpatient practice and then
we became the inpatient hospital us and
so half the date nights of the month I
was on call as a hospitalist and I was
working three days a week in the office
and then two days a week as a clinical
terminology for a contractor who was
doing work with the Veterans
Administration and after doing that
about five or six years seven eight
years I taught myself while I'm working
like two and a half FTEs and I was
pretty much on call whenever I was on
call I was getting called in and so I
thought okay yeah and I have to think
think yourself what do you love to do
and what's paying the bills and I really
loved taking care of patients
I really enjoyed taking care of patients
but what I realized was that quality of
life was gonna come from doing
informatics work full-time and so I had
the opportunity to talk to SMS
it was a very rapidly growing healthcare
IT company about working with them I'll
tell you a little bit more about that
and so I've been with SMS about 19
months now as their team I'll it's been
an interesting 19 months so as with a
lot of things I do when you need a
definition good place to go with
Wikipedia so their definition of 4cm IO
is a healthcare executive which I agree
generally responsible fell to
informatics I agree platform depends
working with clinic IT staff I think in
general that's true to support efficient
design implementation and use of health
technology within a healthcare
organization or at least in my case for
healthcare organizations so looking
around at other folks who are cm iOS and
as part of prepping for this I
interviewed a few of my friends who are
cm iOS we looked at at the settings
where cm Iowa's work and the most common
ones are ones you're familiar with that
work in hospitals or for hospital
systems and so I wanted to introduce two
other areas with some of you may have
not have thought of where see my OHS can
be have a place and one is with a
systems integrator and the other are
with product vendors and before I joined
SMS I had no idea what a systems
integrator is there's anyone here have a
sense of what a systems integrator is
okay me neither so a systems integrators
are kind of a term used for large
companies that do work either
implementing software into a system or
developing software and they're
generally thought of in the federal
space so you hewlett-packard
although they make printers and other
technology their systems integrators
they they can be hired and they try to
win contracts to develop software and so
do we
an SMS there's several of these large
system integrators and when I joined SMS
they were just awarded a contract
vehicle called transformation
transformation 21
it's called t4 and it's a VA Veterans
Administration contract vehicle and
they're only 15 prime contractors on
that vehicle which means that every the
15 had to be pre-qualified the show that
they had the capabilities in the
background and knowledge and the
capability to to win and carry out
contracts for the VA and sms was one of
the what's considered a service-disabled
veteran-owned small business which is a
distinction similar to minority status
or small business status or women-owned
status and so they were looking to grow
and what that's one of the reasons they
they hired me on because they knew that
with this contract vehicle there would
be a lot of work doing healthcare work
for for VA so product vendors I'm sure
you're all familiar with your EHR
vendors device
vendors other software as well as
professional services and then as we
mentioned the the healthcare provider
organizations not only the ones small
community rural community but healthcare
systems as well as we have to consider
that the federal healthcare providers
Veterans Administration Department of
Defense Indian Health Service so they're
all providers so in my role as a CMIO
for SMS when I went into interviewed
with executives they really didn't know
what exactly sumaya would do for them so
in preparing for the interview and
discussions with them I kind of laid out
a four-pronged approach that I did and a
friend a colleague with another large
systems integrator he had a similar kind
of view and so I looked at who would be
my audience that I would be interacting
with and how could I be of service to
them and so the first prong were the
executives the folks that owned the
company
it's a SMS is still a privately owned
company and in that area I'm an advisor
I work with them to help them develop
their healthcare IT strategy and what
does that mean it means looking at the
things that SMS does well the things
that SMS wants to do
the healthcare their existing market
which right at the beginning was the the
Veterans Administration 95% of their
business was veterans in it where they
want to see their market grow into other
federal health care providers now we
work with the Department of Defense now
we also work with CMS the Centers for
Medicare Medicaid Services we want to
grow that into social security and then
ultimately ideally into the commercial
area but how do you do that you have to
know what you're capable of doing and
what the market needs what are the
market drivers and how do you develop
those capabilities within the company in
order to meet those needs and provide a
service or value to your your customers
the second aspect is that I work
directly on projects I work on a
contract for standards and terminology
services for the VA which works to
maintain their codes which is what I
actually had been doing for about 10
years as soon as I finished the
fellowship so it wasn't wasn't terribly
new which was helpful because when
contracts change you need people who
know what was happening on contract to
help proposals and such I worked on that
I also do some work for CMS to help
support their S&I framework the
standards and interoperability framework
on one of their initiatives called the
electronic submission of medical
documentation and I provide subject
matter expertise in informatics and
particularly in standards CDA's kind of
technology we were working with I spent
a fair amount of time in business
development which means I go out and I
meet with clients and customers try to
understand what their issues are where
what their goals and what their
directions are how SMS might be able to
with our capabilities support them it's
a challenge because it's you're out
there you're working with with clients
but when you're in the federal space you
they can only talk about so much and
you're trying to provide get an
understanding well enough so that when
they release a contract request you
respond in a knowledgeable way and
formulate a solution for them that that
recognizes their their the environment
there they're working in the issues that
they have and how your company will
provide a well thought-out solution and
so that's the other part of business
development I do which is proposal
writing which I never really thought I
would do but turns out to be a fair
amount which is taking one of these
contract requests they have a problem
they say address this as a software
approach and so I I work with a team of
writers and account managers and try to
develop give them the healthcare
perspective so if it's software like the
emergency room emergency department
information system for VA my
understanding of the emergency room
helps them understand how the software
needs to work and how it needs things
issues that need to be addressed in
order to enhance that software and then
lastly is activities like this outreach
so it's all the outward facing things
being part of a mia going to hl7
meetings and understanding stamp
standards development going to hims and
meeting with potential you know partners
understanding try to understand
technology so those are kind of the four
areas that I direct my time and any
given day I can slide it into one of
those slots so questions so far
yes break that down in any kind of
percentages
there's a sort of stable percentages as
a variable it buries the the projects
I'm pretty steadily doing about twenty
to twenty five percent of my time the
the STS project the standards VA
standards it's in a sustainment so I
just need to provide some backup if they
have issues for the ONC work it's pretty
regular conference calls and then work
outside the conference calls to prepare
the presentations for the discussion
with the the wider community business
development pretty easily fifty percent
of the time working on proposals meeting
with
potential partners evaluating potential
partners technologies and seeing if it's
something we want to know more about so
that if we encounter an issue with the
customer brings up we can say oh we have
a partner that has a technology we think
can meet your needs
so understanding partners technologies
do other questions so commercial vendor
I only know of a handful of CIOs in this
space but it's very focused on on their
technology and in the same way my slides
my first one the systems integrators
healthcare IT strategy a vendor has to
have that as well but their's is focused
on their product say an EMR you know
they have to know their markets they
have to know what direction the company
is going what the market is looking for
and so that's where the CMIO would
provide their their input for an EMR
vendor you know Meaningful Use is a
major driver right now so if an EMR
developer doesn't understand meaningful
use criteria they're in trouble
and if they don't have someone who can
translate those meaningful use criteria
and standards into down to the
application requirements for the
developers they're in trouble so they're
similar those could be involved in
product development as well as sales to
a certain extent you know selling
promoting the the product to hospitals
or end-users and then providing product
supports if you're an EMR vendor you
might a hospital may have issues with
say document templates you might have
clinicians involved and this is not just
to CMIO but also other health you know
uh clinical informatics is who
understand because CMIO can work in
isolation but probably isn't as
effective working in isolation and I'll
talk about a few other things and then
there see - for consultant companies to
do consulting - there go in and help a
hospital as they're doing their initial
internal evaluation of their
infrastructure and their resources in
order to help them prepare for
purchasing new software applications and
such so this is the area where you've
probably seen the most cm iOS working in
hospitals or in hospital systems and
again healthcare IT strategy CMIO is in
my view
put pieces together put the clinical
with the to the extent that they're
technologically minded the technology
together and then understanding the
healthcare environment and and
understanding the drivers and how those
drivers affect the business of the
corporation that that they're working
for so they may be involved in IT
evaluations which would be a small rural
hospital saying we need an EMR what are
our what's our Hardware what's our
networks what's their culture are the
docs are they gonna be enthusiastic or
they can be supportive and then what are
the one of the things we need so that we
can then put out a request for proposals
for an EMR and then how do we evaluate
these EMRs so a CMIO is a good person or
a clinical informatics person to help
lead those evaluations they're going to
be an integral part and plenty has been
written and and word-of-mouth
discussions about implementation and
there are lots of aspects of
implementation including how the
institution is prepared not only
physically with their networks and
they're struck infrastructure and their
software but the huge part is culture
and change management and our is and how
successful can you be and being
advocates and how well did you plan on
rolling it out it's a huge part of the
CM iovers role I haven't done it
personally but but I've had I spoken
with some folks and it can be a big
challenge can be a huge challenge
because you have to work with a lot of
Doc's
and as a doctor they can be difficult so
even following implementation providing
support ongoing support to the clinical
staff understanding their needs talking
to them and and and then being the
liaison to the the IT staff so that
you're a bridge because the the clinical
staff has some idea of how the
technology is supposed to work and how
it either helps their their workflow or
impedes that workflow and we have to be
able to communicate that to the IT staff
and so we can provide support but we
also want to be able to have the
clinicians
recognize that there are limitations to
all technology it it's not a panacea and
you can't do everything I see also the
cm I was working on quality improvement
taking the informatics skilled
understanding data and how data works in
order to support improving doing
reporting for quality and things like
meaningful use in compliance in Jayco
and then one of the big topics in
discussion with pretty much all the CMOS
I've talked to it is clinical duties
it's a challenge I think coming in as a
CMIO
there's there's several different paths
there's the path where you are a
clinician and you have a good base of
clinical work or you have a good base of
informatics work into becoming a CMIO
and the challenge is if you're at an
institution and you're your clinician
the challenge is you have to you have to
have your what's the word I want if
they've demonstrated that you know how
to practice medicine you have to have
credibility and that credibility comes
from having a practice medicine for a
long time and in there you have to put
in that you have some credibility isn't
infirm at doing informatics and it's
really hard I think that's why those the
early CM iOS were the clinicians in on
the medical staff were also very tech
savvy who kind of learned the
informatics is because they got involved
as a physician champion of technology
and an implementation and then they
because they were part of that medical
staff that grew with that medical staff
they they earned that respect but as a
CIO
one of my friends at another academic
institution he started out as a that way
but he continues to do a hospital work
hospitalists work a week a month that's
a lot it's it's a it's a lot of work but
that enables him to be able to say to
the the clinicians not only the the
physicians but also nurses I'm using the
same system I'm asking
you to use and so there's a lot of
credibility the challenge is when he's
on service he's working 8 10 12 hours a
day and he's really not available to the
administrative staff because he's taking
care of patients so that becomes part of
the challenge and honestly that's the
challenge I'm facing at this point too
because I was practicing full-time to
about 18 months ago and then practice
part-time as a hospitalist
for about 12 months and I'm at the point
we have to decide because my company is
not a hospital I'm not going to get
extra credit for doing clinical work so
I have to find that separately and then
you get into the discussion which I
think it's always important about the
work family balance so it's it's going
to be an ongoing discussion because we
would need if a hospital and the the
CMIO of the clinic lefur Madison values
that clinical time they have to don't
have to fight for it and help people
understand and then one of the other
personal things is I'm an internist and
a pediatrician and it's hard enough to
keep up with one or the other so now
trying to keep up with all both of those
as well as what's happening in
informatics there's only so many hours
of the day so those are some things to
consider a topic that comes up very very
frequently is who it is a CMIO report to
so there's a it's a sea of seas so you
have this chief executive officer you
have the chief information officer you
have the chief medical officer who's
invariably a physician then you have the
chief operating officer and then you
have other see folks in there that I
didn't list because they're relatively
new not the chief nursing officer but
you may have a chief nursing officer
somewhere in there you may have a chief
quality officer somewhere in there and
so the challenge is each the
relationships with each of these folks
comes with pros and cons if the the
relationship with directly reporting to
see you know CEO is great assuming the
CEO understands the value of the CMIO
can have the discussions and you can
have influence and such but if you
report to the CEO as a CMIO and the CIO
reports to the CM the CEO there's the
possibility of conflicting goals and
that's why the CM is so important for
the CMIO to be part of the executive
staff to have everyone has that shared
mission vision and strategy and
execution and you know if you if you're
reporting the CEO and and you have a
budget then you have to manage budgets
and some folks like managing budgets
some folks don't and so we talk we have
these discussions about influence versus
authority and so in each of these roles
it can change the suggestion from one of
the texts I wrote which is really
actually really good called the CMIO
survival guide published by him
talks about probably a direct
relationship to the CIO with a dotted
line relationship to the the CMO because
the CMO is in most hospitals is has
quite a bit of authority and definitely
a lot of influence because they were
well respected by the medical staff and
you you need that that support of the
medical staff when you do
implementations one of my friends that I
talk to in discussion of this is that
he's currently the CIO and CMIO for an
institution and the reason he felt like
he's done that really well is that he
really well mentored when he was a CMIO
he had a really good relationship with a
cio and it kind of needless to say
anytime you get any job you want to
develop good relationships and good
rapport and I'm talking a moment a
little bit about politics question yes
yeah I can see the structure in a
providing organization well what about a
systems integrator or a vendor do we
have a CMO they may actually have a CMO
because what I've come to realize is
some of the the vendors they use CMOS
because they're they didn't feel that
the CM I owe the I part of the CM I was
valid for that person it was valid for
me because I've done in format
it's got some training and it may be
valid for a doc who's been working in
healthcare IT for a long time and has
that cred but if they're there a doc who
comes in to help support a product
without that technical background so
they opt they will use a CMO and
sometimes folks and even an SMS just
call me the CMO just because they don't
think about it so so some some may have
one or the other I haven't seen any to
head both because see most typically
manage managed medical staff other
question and this this is not this is
not an org chart this is just okay so
just a few things that uh key skills I
thought were important for an effective
CMIO one is kind of core informatics
roles and I think it's been it's being
recognized it is recognized by a mia and
and we'll talk a bit about the boards in
a little bit but having those those core
skills and now that informatics
fellowships are more readily available
and that knowledge through like amy has
ten by ten there's the certificate
program here and other institutions that
knowledge is can be gained as opposed to
being gained in the past through your
experience as I noted in all three of
the settings strategy the CMIO
puts pieces together as a clinician
understanding the environment
understanding the issues of Medicare
Medicaid payers how referrals are done
how you order a drug those are all all
goes into that strategic thinking so
that when you when you I read a lot of
trade web pages healthcare IT news the
hims because you want to say oh
something's coming down from ONC or
meaningful use yet the kind of positive
okay what what does that have to do with
my company if you're a mobile health
care app developer you better be aware
that that FDA is developing rules on
certifying
mobile applications and if you're not
you know thinking about that you you
have to react as opposed to being able
to provide the strategic thinking to
your company you have to provide
leadership your leading groups of people
especially in the hospital in
implementation so you have to understand
how to be work well in the team I only
have to say I think of the old-school
physicians as the paternalistic do what
I say is going by the wayside clinicians
in general at least want for my aspect
and for 4cm is you become the the
trusted advisor so you have to be able
to work on those skills foster the
skills so that you can demonstrate that
you can hear the concerns of your peers
and be able to respond to them good
skills of good leadership communication
is huge and hopefully I'm demonstrating
that okay right now but a lot of what
you do as a CMIO is to translate to
distill information in one setting to
another setting so the your product
developers aren't clinicians they or
asked create a screen that's oh I can
order a drug okay what does that mean
what does it mean to order a drug drug
names drug routes timing things like
that and that's where the you have to be
able to communicate workflow to the to
the developers and to the technical
folks and you have to communicate some
of the technical aspects to the the
clinicians one great example I worked on
the link and everybody familiar with
luring okay I hope so
good clinical no titles for the VA and
as part of that I I took three sites no
titles which were 200,000 no titles
these are distinct no titles that people
use to apply to create actual instances
of notes these aren't actual instances
in ever and I've broke them down and
helped worked with link to to elaborate
the the axes you know the
the author setting type of service and
so I went back and we had group of
clinicians to try to walk through these
and try to help them understand what the
value of letting go of doctrine to wins
blue clinic note which only means
something to doctor no end and if you
know what the blue clinic is to internal
medicine outpatient progress now that
has value but you have to communicate
that value to the clinicians because
they they have their workflow they do
they do it well it works for them works
well for the care of their patient in
front of them but yes learn how to
communicate that to help them understand
that it's now no longer you and your
patient it's you your patient their
providers other institutions that
provide care and how do we make that
better so that we can provide better
care in the big picture
so continuous self education that's
actually huge because in in in my role I
find this to be the most challenging
because there's standards to keep up on
standards development there's regulation
to keep up on there are a myriad of
different technologies to try to
understand and so I I spend a fair
amount of time getting questions from
the operation staff about you know you
help us understand this better so I go
and I I read up on it and try to give
them perspective on it so you know we're
all at adult learner so you recognize
that need to continuously improve here
ah I also I think the Board
Certification ultimate value is yet to
be determined
however my personal view is there's go
there there's going to be value in it
but maybe not for five or ten years
because as the the recognition of the
value the CMO increases there'll be more
opportunities for for individuals to
become cm iOS but at larger institutions
that are I've gone beyond the
implementing an EHR there at the how do
we use the EHR for research how do we
use it to improve patient quality
quality how do we become trend cutting
edge that's the area where somebody
who's either formally trained and/or
board-certified that's gonna provide
value if you put me up against somebody
who's doing do this 20 years and I'm
doing the 10 and I have a board
certification they'll probably go after
somebody with a lot more experience but
if you take one of the reports I saw
showed some distribution and over the
last three or four years the the age
group or cm iOS that's growing the most
is between 41 and 50 so it's a still
relatively young group and so I think
the board certification in the same way
you have a board-certified cardiologist
who heads the cardiology department it's
seen stands to reason that if you're
gonna have a clinical informatics
department or yeah you're gonna have
somebody who's excuse you some
reassurance so a couple of other things
to consider compensation I think in
general compensation for see my OHS is
similar to the other kind of second-tier
c-suite folks the the CIO maybe not the
CIA over the CML there can be a fair
amount of travel I travel a lot in my
role because I my my office in Salt Lake
City is remote from our headquarters in
McLean Virginia so I travel once a month
to McLane mainly to maintain
relationships
and be there well that's where the
executives are to have that face-to-face
time
that's the conference calls all the time
but you have to consider travel to
professional meetings like hymns or am
dis which is the Association of medical
directors of information systems which
is kind of CMI IOT's professional
society but other if you're going to be
involved in hl7 there's there can be
potentially lots and lots of travel and
so you have to factor that into the work
factoring in clinical time as we have
already discussed the notion of
influence versus authority the howhow
see my own role has been implemented
varies from institution to institution
and I think it varies depending on their
level of comfort their size and such and
so there see my o--'s who who who lead a
group of folks who report directly to
them and they do things like meaningful
use reporting or working with the
clinicians and so you may have your own
budget and you have to direct folks or
where it started with me with with SMS
I'm by myself like I report to the CEO
and the executive VP and what kind of
other side so about I always like to
joke and say I have no authority in this
company but I have some influence and so
where that is important is that when you
don't have authority and you can't make
things happen you have to be a good
communicator and collaborator so that
the executives or other folks that you
have to work with who do have the
authority to get things done understand
the value of what the principles that
you're trying to communicate and really
with any kind of executive with
executive kind of jobs they're all there
are there's culture if you are a new
CMIO and you happen to join a mid-sized
rural hospital and the docs there have
gone through a bad implementation
they're gonna have a bad feel about
informatics and so you have to be able
you have to know that advance and ask
yourself is there something I want to
try to get myself into or if you're at a
teaching hospital and you had a bad
implementation well it's a little bit
different because who bears the brunt of
health care in a teaching hospital the
residents and the residents brought it
rotate out every three years you get a
new badge and so you have it you know so
the how IT is viewed by the by the
medical staff is really important and if
you don't have shared vision with the
other executives you could be at odds
and so kind of increasing your awareness
of how to work in that environment is
important so so I think support of the
executive leadership is really key
having having being an institution where
they recognize the value of health IT as
a way of not only improving care but
ideally you know improving the bottom
line which is another discussion but the
value of health IT and support of the
community and then expectation
management I have to say I'm doing an
okay job with expectation management in
my role because I think some folks in
the company when they see I'm a doctor I
do informatics oh so you must know
everything about medicine and only that
you know every kind of technology and
you have to say no I don't but you know
I'll work with you guys to understand
that you're part of a team and Rob and I
were he led the research and innovations
now this is CTO and work and I'm
building out a clinical informatics
group in the company I have my first
reporting doc my second reporting doc
and so we're looking at ways of working
together so that we have we're mutually
collaborating and not working at all so
so where's the future well I think
there's gonna be more seeing my house
there are a lot of hospitals out there
and there are a lot of them still using
paper and meaningfully used in high-tech
are encouraging them to to move to EHRs
and they're gonna need some help and so
there's there's jobs out there for not
only seeing my OS but yeah a clinical
format assists in general with this kind
of expertise you're gonna have more
responsibilities I think along with CMIO
and CIO
being able to lead departments making
making your decisions about how to
improve patient care and then trying to
communicate with that the leadership to
get funding to the type of work
effectiveness through things like
showing that that the implementation of
technology improves the bottom line or
at a minimum has to should improve
patient care and then where do these new
technologies come in you know the rural
hospital isn't gonna be looking at doing
genomic medicine or predictive analytics
but a institution might go Hsu a lot of
data a lot of knowledge lot of expertise
these are where this type of
understanding and leadership is going to
be important and then we talked about
the board certification I think it's
worthwhile I'm I'm going on I fly to
Philly on Friday to attend the three-day
board review course by dr. Hirsch so I'm
convinced that it's important it's I
think it's it's it's a viable career
course and to the extent that you can
plan it out it's helpful if I think
being involved in implementation would
be a very worthwhile worthwhile
experience if you ultimately think you
want to be a CMIO because there's a lot
of it to be done and not only is the
first time kind of implementation but
when hospitals say that was a terrible
implementation they rip it out and they
want to put something else in because I
think that's gonna be the next phase in
the next five to ten years because as
the the younger doctors are coming
through and have worked with CPRS and
institutions of EHRs there we overcome
the frustration aspect of technology
implementation I think any of you who
are doc we've done training you show up
on day one at hospital a and within 48
hours you figured out what you need to
do with that system to get the work done
and then at the end of the month you go
to hospital B and you do it all over
again
so adoption isn't going to be the issue
it's gonna be expectations
and so they're gonna be a lot more savvy
and I'll have a much higher expectations
for a trial 19 in the future so
questions please
yes
so you were talking about physicians and
other clinical people who sort of become
cm i/os and then half the backfill on
informatics do you that that's sort of a
common old story or their stories the
other way where people have an
informatics background and not very much
clinical experience who then have to
learn more about hospitals and how they
really work and and whatnot or you know
do you know I don't that pretty rare I
don't have as many example I don't have
I don't have any examples of that I
think the majority are doing that I've
done the clinical work and then enter
into the or have continued clinical work
like me and then entered into that role
it's it's really a challenge and it's
one of my personal fears about getting
out of clinical medicine is that once
you get out you know they say that the
medical knowledge doubles every 10 years
how do you get back in I think the
having the informatics experience you
then if you were gonna look at the
clinical scenarios then you deal with
you you you would have to have your
subject matter experts because even even
even as an SI mio informaticists I
recognize I'm a generalist I don't know
I'm have familiarity with the ER
workflow and that's important but
they're probably details that that I
don't know and so if you don't have the
as extensive the clinical experience you
could get the subject matter experts
that that wouldn't be that hard yes the
only one I've ever known to do this with
Paul Clayton he was the CMIO of of
Intermountain Healthcare and he was like
you know he's an informatics luminary
but he has a PhD doesn't have an MD and
he basically learned the clinical
content so well from his subject matter
experts that he could do that role and I
think he found it a challenge a good
challenge but
challenged to engaging so if you really
want to be engaged with clinicians and
work with them very closely and bring
the informatics you know close to the to
them then that's a role that you know
you should think about to see if you
know developing up to as an information
so just a follow-up on that I mean do
you see this changing you know over the
next I mean maybe it's babies changing
maybe it's not what the clinical
informatics subspecialty but with
informatics being seen as you know more
recognized as a field and more training
being accessible and more people you
know being interested in doing this who
may or may not have strong clinical
backgrounds do you think that do you
think that the clinical informatics so
specialty will sort of take over that
area and you know block other people out
of this kind of role you know
potentially it is because I think that's
one of the concerns that was raised at a
Mia when they did when dr. Hirsh was on
the panel and they were just discussing
it is there are a couple of requirements
for taking the clinical informatics
portal one is that you hold a board
certification in one of the ABMS boards
so if a someone who's gone to
informatics master's program or PhD
program right after residency or after
med school because I know some have done
it right after med school and didn't do
a any residency they can't sit for one
of those boards and so where does that
fit I think the answer is we don't know
because and also that clinical
informatics isn't available for nurses
who have been practicing who have PhDs
and nursing informatics training so
we're where those all fit I'm not sure
yeah yeah so I think they they hopefully
they tackle this part first and then
figure out where to tackle the other
part because I think having med school
you know an internship of residency you
have core knowledge but that it's that
broad knowledge I think is also valuable
when you get out and practice in the
real world too
it's all a matter of experience and we
can't have all experience that's why we
rely on subject matter experts yes
there's a lot of drivers that are
bringing technology into health systems
what I don't see as much is the
clinician point of view and the patient
point of view and the view that we're
actually delivering care hair and into
the technology development it's it's
very tech oriented and so when I look at
vendors and I look at companies and I
you know I tend to look at you know
who's on our team and sometimes there's
a medical you know expert but a lot of
times they have advisors you know they
have like clinician advisors or
physician advisors and so I wonder I
guess my question is really about where
do you see the value beyond things like
you know implementation and things that
you discuss in bringing the core
business of what you're trying to do
into the technology development and
implementation well I think in the
development part I think it's valuable
to have clinical informatics folks who
in practice working with the developers
as they're developing the technology
whether it's a EMR or a device because
without that kind of experience
I think developers whether they be
software developers or technology make
presumptions about how it's going to be
used and so I think workflow is is
actually huge and that's where the
clinical clinical experience gives you
that I think one of my favorite books
I've read is called the art of
innovation at publish like 10 years 10
or 15 years ago a company called IDEO
they helped you guys were a member of
the the handspring was like
palm they tell a story about going out
to to a cardiology suite at the hospital
because they were helping a catheter
manufacturer improve their catheter and
they they were watching the cardiologist
do the procedure and noticed that they
always had to kind of twist a certain
way because there was something it's
some issue with the catheter and had
they not observed that or recognize that
or worked with the clinician you know
you start selling these and cardiologist
I'm not going to use it it's too
complicated or too wonky and so the I
think in trying to answer your question
you need that the informatics is one of
the groups of folks that are gonna bring
that that workflow to the vet to the
application because they bring that
understanding I understand that and I
think everyone here under understands
that but I find that sometimes it's the
organizations and the companies that
don't understand bringing in that
clinical perspective and that user
perspective it's going to help them be
more successful because it's more
focused on the real world and it really
you know again I I find it interesting
that there's some of the biggest vendors
yeah so I got a deal with a lot of
vendors okay so I just find it
interesting that many of them don't have
a clinician and and I and I want it's
like what is the problem here what is
the lack of understanding and how can we
help drive that recognition of the value
because in the end there you know I
think they're cutting themselves short I
think it's one of it maybe they don't
realize that there there's that's
available that that the this kind of
training is available so it might be at
that part of it as someone who has to
talk to vendors so a reasonable question
is what is your clinical support in your
developing your technology that's a very
that's a valid thing and if they say oh
well we have an advisory
or a lot of companies instead of having
a full-time technical clinical person
they have advisory boards and I'm always
worried about what does that mean
but maybe it's a take them to retreat
and show them the software they haven't
reviewed the software technology but but
my role in is is to help bring that
clinical perspective to at least the
clinical contracts that we're looking at
just so that the technical folks
understand why is it that standard
terminology is so important but I talk
about that all the time with them and
you know meaningful use and in those
aspects so I think it maybe it's more
education thus a lot
my background is all technical so I've
seen some of the work flows within the
VA which are enlightening and and I've
had long discussions with with dr. P
about the medical end of it which is a
piece I've never had in my career so
it's it's very useful from my
perspective to gain that that broad
background helps me be a better
generalist helps me look at how we would
better solution a product how how we
would choose you know one technology
over another 14 vendors of for EHR
systems
there's together but 14 vendors is gonna
be a challenge how do you know what your
thoughts are you know that's um well
you're counting the port like the bigger
ones
yeah with a myriad of smaller ones out
there as well who may or may not have
the support they need to be able to meet
meaningful use and that kind of
compliance my sense is that in 10 years
the strong will survive but
unfortunately those who didn't buy one
of those strong will have to figure out
what to do a new system and that's a
great area for clinical informatics what
do you do with the old data how do you
make that data available useful so there
I think there are lots of jobs available
one of the things that's probably
depending on the community you work
where you want to work we're fortunate
in Salt Lake City that we have a pretty
vibrant informatics community with
Intermountain Healthcare the University
of Utah the to the universities universe
Utah Valley University and Weber State
are starting a health IT and I'm
participating in a health IT so if
you're willing to move though that
there's a lot of IT jobs it's all part
of the consideration other questions
well thank you very much oh yes you
mentioned the challenges of continuous
education and you mentioned health
healthcare IT news that you follow in
hymns there are other things that you
read regularly or how do you do you have
a kind of a rigorous way of staying in
touch or is it more attention it's catch
yes when when I when I can and it's
often problem focused trying to gather
information to help an understanding of
a specific technology or well thank you
very much everyone
appreciate your time